bonjour 7,8 week-end une émission dédiée
à vos loisirs aux événements culturels
qui ont fait l'actualité de la semaine
écoulée dans quelques instants nous
recevrons avant d'appui zerg du centre
de port royal pour parler là d'où nous
on est dédié à la nature elle aura lieu
ce dimanche c'est d'abord un
anniversaire en ce vendredi 27 septembre
un bon anniversaire au théâtre de 50 ans
gulli qui fête ses 20 ans inaugurée donc
le 27 septembre 1993 tombe bien le
théâtre de saint quentin après trois
années de travaux est devenue il ya
vingt ans le plus grand théâtre
construit au cours des dernières années
en ile-de-france alors c'est la seule
scène nationale à des yvelines et là
vous découvrez les coulisses le théâtre
accueille environ 60000 spectateurs par
an il a été réalisé par un archet
d'architectes stanislas isère à la bonne
anniversaire au théâtre de saint quentin
le tourisme a le vent en poupe dans le
département le budget dédié à ce secteur
a été multiplié par deux par le conseil
général le même conseil général à
l'initiative d'un coffret y box qui
offre des réductions sur 80 à 4 sites
explication claire combi
ligue red box est disponible dans le
commerce depuis mardi un coffret qui
regroupe 78 offres culturelles de
loisirs ou d'hébergement à prix bradés
-50% navy de telles visites de musées ou
encore paint ball il s'agissait de de
partir d'une réflexion très simple qui
était de dire aujourd'hui l'été les gens
partent moins loin moins longtemps en
vacances proposons leur de redécouvrir
ou de découvrir tout simplement les
yvelines
l'entreprise martin co est habitué aux
boks en tous genres mail y box et son
premier partenariat avec une
collectivité l'initiative vient en effet
du conseil général qui espère booster le
secteur du tourisme on a fait le calcul
à peu près si les acheteurs les futurs
acheteurs de cet eee box
utilisent tout ce qui leur est offert
ils font une économie de 3000 euros donc
vous voyez pour un investissement de
moins de 30 euros c'est une bon
placement mais au delà de ça c'est bien
entendu destinée à mieux faire connaître
les yvelines
dans le département le tourisme reste en
effet peu développée à l'exception du
site du château de versailles ce projet
de boxe est dans les cartons depuis un
an et demi il a fallu dans un premier
temps convaincre les partenaires les
hôtels qui assurent principalement une
clientèle d'affaires en semaine ils y
ont vu un moyen de combler leur faible
taux d'occupation du week end en moyenne
moins de 50% donc c'est une façon de
bloquer dans les yvelines nous nos
clients potentiels et ainsi et siphonner
un peu paris qui qui attire vraiment
trop par rapport à lui mais leur offre
le sont disponibles que le week-end
toutes les activités du coffret peuvent
être utilisés une fois dans la limite
d'un an
et puis si lui la une à la directrice
d'yveline tourisme était sur le plateau
de file echo l'émission économique
hebdomadaire sur tv fil 78 pour
présenter cette y boxe bien sûr et puis
parler plus largement du tourisme dans
le département un budget je voulais 10 1
qui a été multiplié par deux cette année
et notamment avec la création de sites
internet dédiés
on écoute vous avez également créé un
site de réservation d'hébergements un
site de sortie mais c'est pas fini et
ses copines donc le site
sortir tiraille bing.fr propose des
idées de sorties donc pour les yvelinois
les franciliens ou même ceux qui sont en
séjour dans le département donc on a
plein de choses plein d'idées pour pour
s'occuper pendant ses loisirs pendant ce
week-end et puis le site week-end qui
sort le 15 octobre effectivement propose
des séjours pour augmenter les retombées
économiques sur le territoire et puis
favoriser le développement des de ce
qu'on appelle les taux d'occupation dans
l'hôtellerie et le dernier à venir qui
sort le 9 décembre prochain à la fin de
l'année est destiné à valoriser tout ce
qui est loisirs nature
la randonnée les bases de loisirs avec
les activités nautiques les golfs tout
ce qui est à faire en plein air et avec
ces sites finalement vous vous ouvrez un
autre public les événements étaient
particulièrement destiné aux yvelinois
là vous essayer d'attirer également des
touristes étrangers patatrac oui sur le
site week-end qui sort le 15 octobre
effectivement il est destiné à si bien
public français et étranger de proximité
comme les néerlandais les anglais les
belges qui ont déjà goûté entre
guillemets à paris qui sonde est venu
déjà plusieurs fois ce que nous on
appelle dans notre jargon les repeaters
qui sont venus plusieurs fois donc et
qui ont envie de voir un petit peu ce
qui est autour de paris et donc
forcément les yvelines ils ont déjà un
peu goûté puisqu'ils sont venus à
versailles et effectivement il en iran
ces jours donc on leur propose des
hôtels de charme pour les amoureux pour
d une famille qui pourrait venir aussi
en pleine nature passer un bon moment
voilà et le tourisme c'est évidemment un
vecteur économique important une source
de rentrées d'argent notamment les
productions de films et de téléfilms et
justement en ce moment à saint quentin
en yvelines vous avez peut-être remarqué
ce tournage un tournage qui se déroule
jusqu'au 8 octobre la réalisatrice
claire de la rochefoucauld qui a déjà
signé plusieurs épisodes de la série
télé ris police scientifique prépare bug
la vie sur france 2 avec notamment la
comédienne virginie hocq qui a joué dans
incognito avec franck dubosc et bénabar
alors il y sera question de femmes
opérées du cancer du sein et de leur
parcours pour reprendre goût à la vie
une comédie sociale et sentimentale
annonce la société docside production ce
sera à découvrir en 2014 et j'en profite
aussi pour vous rappeler les actions qui
sont menées tout au long du mois
d'octobre pour la lutte contre le cancer
du sein c'est une opération octobre rose
les douze meilleurs joueurs d'échecs du
moment réunit justement en ce moment et
jusqu'au 4 octobre à la commanderie y
ait des templiers à elancourt pour l'adn
dernière étape du grand prix un feed
alors nous avons voulu savoir comment
s'était placé les champions français
anthony rech a fait le point mercredi
sur la compétition
après deux rondes sur les tables élan
courtoise laurent frayssinet a pris la
tête du tournoi avec une victoire et un
match nul le nommer trois français le
seul à s'être imposés avec l'israélien
boris gelfand lors de cette sixième et
dernière étape du grand prix mondial à
31 ans il assume parfaitement son statut
de vice-champion d'europe 2012
c'est une très bonne expérience pour ses
excellents joueurs français d'affronter
les meilleurs joueurs du monde a strong
est en fait laurent frayssinet a déjà
remporté une partie très serrée face à
alexander gris chaud ce qui lui permet
de prendre la tête du tournoi et je
pense que c'est une belle récompense
pour lui
mais lors de ce troisième match il aura
fort à faire face à l'italien fabiano
caruana troisième joueur mondial de son
côté l'autre français etienne bacrot a
déjà concédé deux matches nuls le numéro
deux tricolore a jusqu'au 4 octobre date
de la fin du tournoi pour débloquer son
compteur victoire outre la dotation de
120000 euros sur le tournoi d'elancourt
l'enjeu sportif est de taille puisque
les deux premières places seront
directement qualificatif pour le tournoi
des candidats 2014 dont le vainqueur
affrontera le champion du monde en titre
allez un tout autre sujet maintenant on
va aller à saint lambert des bois la
direction du centre port royal avec vous
avant d'accuser un bon jour est venu
pour nous parler d'une journée dédiée à
la nature qui a lieu ce dimanche mais
d'abord première curiosité pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas le centre de port
royal ça n'a rien à voir avec le centre
de port royal à manille des am alive à
saint-lambert le voit qu'est ce qu'on y
fait dans ce sens est un centre de
séminaires pour les entreprises on
accueille des entreprises
toute la semaine donc on a dit celle de
réunions cinquante et une chambre et un
grand restaurant donc sur une journée ou
plusieurs jours et voilà on est la forêt
on connaît surtout les au réseau voilà
sa laine on est juste à côté on estime
juste à codage et dans ce centre d'un
séminaire organisé aussi du coût des
animations qui sont voile alors là
plutôt d'ordre ludique même si vous
accueillez entrepris de ce dimanche dont
parlait de cette journée nature il ya
différents quartiers en voilà c'est une
journée donc dédié à la nature on a
souhaité sensibiliser un maximum de
public sur la nature l'écologie le
développement durable tout en insistant
sur le fait que
toutes les animations et stands sont
gratuits donc voilà c'est pour toute la
famille s'est réparti effectivement au
quartier car tiens c'est quartier jardin
quartier développement durable
producteurs locaux également le midi un
buffet avec les produits locaux est
servi donc on est en partenariat avec le
parc naturel régional l'eau pilou
fiscaux parce que thor locaux c'est des
producteurs de dupes énerve du parfum
que voilà et bien demeurer qui dit oui
donc fromages légumes charcuterie donc
on peut goûter et alors on peut goûter
aussi si vous avez parlé de l'opi c'est
l'office pour la protection des insectes
et voilà il est basé à guyancourt alors
en plus ça veut dire qu'on va pouvoir
manger des insectes
téméraire
dégustation plante là ça va aller voir
dire effectivement en dégustation
d'insectes
c'est possible également il ya un an
partenariat aussi avec renault donc il
ya des essais de véhicules électriques
chercher le rapport entre renault et les
inserts
général la nature voilà sur le sort de m
c'est la twizy notamment exactement où
prévenir et ici la twizy affluence et la
zone ces dispositions donc je reviens
sur les sur les animaux parce que il ya
aussi alors pas pouvoir toucher des
reptiles mais en tout cas une radio qui
sera là le résidu raison nous avait pas
et aurait agi de quoi s'agit-il
c'est bye communique sur sur les
reptiles au quotidien sur les infos sur
sur certains insectes en particulier
donc voilà ils vont commenter au long de
la journée vous nous accompagner à ce
moment à part ça c'est la partie animaux
vivants j'ai envie de dire c'est il ya
aussi toute une partie où on peut aussi
apprendre par exemple la taille et des
arbustes voilà donc là elle appartient
un peu plus jardin donc taille
d'arbustes élagage
jardin potager pour les débutants
il ya du compostage aussi
la récupérateur d'eau de toutes les
explications sur ce domaine là il ya
également des conférences sur la gestion
du stress lorsque les insectes celle en
préparant la mission j'ai été un peu
étonné que la gestion du stress vient
interférer à la fois dans le monde des
insectes à la fois à ses côtés bien être
détente c'est
on a voulu mêler tous ses atouts pour
nous c'est lié tout ça en fait la nature
la nature et bien-être voilà il la
nature et bien-être voilà qu'un quartier
aussi dédié au développement durable et
là forcément il y aura les autres saint
lambert et oblige et elle sera présente
à son partenaire avec nous il se régale
on pourra goûter votre saint lambert oui
moi je ne sais pas si on peut repérer
une ou par rapport à une autre au mais
en tout cas les ca service pour cette
journée dans votre probable j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient un atelier le nombre est
un peu étrange pour moi donc voilà c'est
marche méditative en pleine conscience
alors expliquez moi qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va marcher alors on regarde
oreilles oui mais non pas dans la forêt
et donc il ya une animation sur la
concentration sur l'évasion à travers la
forêt est une méditation et près ça se
termine dans une salle sous forme de
relaxation d'accor d'étendre c'est
toujours un peu à peu ça peut étonner de
toute façon voilà il ya des choses assez
étonnante il ya aussi apprivoiser la sa
phobie des insectes là ce qu'on peur en
fait à fait d'accord dans les années
dans une pièce avec des araignées voilà
une tête comme ça sur france 2
effectivement dans une pièce et on doit
marcher donc ses enfants dans cette
affaire fort boyard au sein de non non
il n'y aurait pas d'insectes dans la
salle un petit mot aussi parce que dans
tout ce que j'ai lu il ya des choses
assez amusante il ya un grand jeu qui
s'appelle la sphère de la fourmi rouge
oui ça c'est une enquête pour les
enfants et puis pour les adultes
également et
donc la fourmi rouge a été écrasée donc
on doit chercher par qui est donc les
enfants doivent se rendre sur tous les
stands pour récolter des indices et à la
fin trouvé qui est responsable de
la mort de la fobio c'est la sphère de
la fourmi rouge est réservé aux enfants
mais bon si on est un peu un grand
enfant je vois là aussi aller chercher
le vilain il a la forme encore c'est la
troisième édition
alors à qui ça s'adresse vraiment aux
familles aux familles vraiment il ya un
quartier enfants donc avec maquillage
peinture
jeux et ça va vraiment vous dire que des
relaxations c'est vraiment ouvert à tous
nous n'a vraiment voulu que tout le
monde puisse venir à sète à cette
journée donc les particuliers on à
communiquer auprès de nos clients mais
aussi sur le village de saint lambert
tous les environs montigny le bretonneux
50 ans qu'on est situé à côté de voisins
de retenue oui peut-être pas précisé à
l'ats me sens du centre de port royal
des joueurs amani voyage
il s'agissait d'un troisième édition
l'an passé vous avez reçu comme une
personne sur six cents personnes la
première année de 300 l'an passé 6 ans
chuck rochelle ou voilà on espère
j'espère vous avez prévu plein
d'insectes à manger là c'est la première
année qui seront là oui ok merci
beaucoup
le plateau pour nous parler de cette
journée dédiée à la nature dédiée aux
animaux et dit aussi au bien être et je
rappelle que ça va mieux donc que
dimanche toute la journée je pense 9h30
18h30 18h et qu'en plus c'est gratuit
donc c'est l'occasion d'aller profiter
des ateliers sont vraiment gratuite ou
tribus fait qu est payant si vous avez
monté des producteurs locaux c'est
payant mais le reste est gratuit donc si
vous voulez mener l enquête et trouvé à
celui qui a écrasé la fourmi rouge
rendez vous au centre de broyage aime
beaucoup le titre parce qu'on ne peut
pas envoyer à la salle envers des mois
merci mignon en plateau allez on reste
aussi en plein air pour suivre un
concours d'attelage de tradition ça
s'est passé en bout y ait une balade
signer au rallye de bi six
chevaux voitures anciennes et meneurs
étaient en compétition ce week end dans
le parc du château de rambouillet
organisé depuis trois ans par le haras
national des bréviaires le concours
international d'attelage de tradition a
réuni une quarantaine de participants
ces collectionneurs de voitures
anciennes modèles d'époque de la fin du
19e ou répliques fidèles sont notamment
jugés pour l'harmonie du couple cheval
voiture
marché qu'un piquet
attelage en simple en perd en tandem
composé de chevaux de poneys et parfois
même dan quelle que soit la catégorie du
concours l'attelage de tradition reste
pour le meneur une vraie passion le
ménage permet d'avoir une équitation à
distance qui est absolument passionnante
et vous menez voyez quatre chevaux avec
juste lui demain ou deux et vous avez
des sensations absolument magique
d'abord le plaisir des fans et puis le
respect de la tradition pas ce sont des
choses qu'on doit transmettre aux
générations futures c'est très important
la france de taipei tellement
accueillants pour les contrôles
tradition on n y revenir très souvent
après trois épreuves réalisé deux jours
la présentation le parcours routier et
la maniabilité nos deux compétiteurs ont
chacun remporté un prix dans leur
catégorie
on a l'impression d'être dans un autre
siècle avec ce reportage à l'est de
cheval et en était également question
dans casque à l'émission à culturel du
mercredi l'a présentée par aurélien de
bissy pour les haras des bréviaires
organise un grand spectacle du 10 au 14
octobre la garde républicaine le
régiment de cavalerie de de paris qui va
se déplacer à rambouillet qui vont nous
présenter deux numéros un numéro un peu
technique de dressage qu'on appelle la
c1 pat42 dressage c'est un car vous
allez avec des figures c'est un peu la
spécialité de la garde républicaine fait
plutôt classique plutôt classique et on
aura un numéro plus original puisque
l'on entrera l'utilisation justement des
chevaux de la garde républicaine lors
notamment des interventions par exemple
des sorties de stades ou des
interventions donc c'est pour montrer la
franchise des chevaux de la garde
républicaine un peu mise en scène est un
peu plus spectaculaires on va dire par
exemple sans tout dévoiler mais est-ce
qu'il y aura des épreuves de foot par
exemple voilà faire passer les chevaux
dans le feu c'est tout ce qui montre la
franchise des des chevaux de la garde
républicaine puisqu'ils doivent être
capables d'intervenir notamment au
milieu urbain est agité
par exemple est un exemple alors du coup
d'essai c'est le côté spectacle
voilà si vous voulez découvrir en savoir
un petit peu plus la garde républicaine
rendez vous donc au haras des bréviaires
du 10 au 13 octobre le festival estival
par nombre d'onces à la sauce de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
s'est déroulée ce jeudi un festival de
la vie étudiante ponctuée par un concert
de boulevard désert le groupe promu aux
victoires de la musique était très
décontracté avant son passage sur scène
on regarde
les joues au foot avant leur concert le
groupe boulevard désert récompensé aux
victoires de la musique 2013 il l'invité
d'honneur du festival balance la sauce
ce jeudi à l'université de versailles
saint quentin les associations en fait
on fait appel à nous pour pour finir
tous leurs journées de sensibilisation
aux associations voilà pour finir par un
concert et ils ont pensé à vouloir
désert et nous on a accepté l'invitation
avec plaisir dans les a connus ces
jeunes étudiantes puisqu'on est on est
tous passés par les universités vont
nous c'était à toulouse donc ces
quelques kilomètres d'ici mais on ya
déjà participé moi j'ai déjà vu des
concerts à toulouse et je trouve ça très
bien qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils fassent ça
ici donc on est très contents d'être là
pour clôturer à ste première journée les
associations et la direction de la vie
étudiante présente pour la sixième
édition aux nouveaux inscrits ou aux
anciens l'étendue des activités
proposées au sein de l'université les
objectifs de ces journées étudiantes et
de favoriser les premiers contacts les
nouveaux arrivants étudiants et les
associations qui sont déjà en place à
l'université c'est aussi con si tu es
beau une journée ludique donc on essaye
de faire vivre et animer le campus une
vingtaine d'associations intervient tout
au long de l'année et facilite la vie
étudiante dans les domaines de la
culture de l'environnement ou encore de
l'aide aux démarches administratives
nous avons
aujourd'hui l'université un certain
nombre d'associations étudiantes celles
ci sont dynamiques et par ces deux
journées elle tente de recruter des
nouveaux adhérents pour pouvoir faire
de nouvelles choses chaque année c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui à tendance actuelle
c'est
c'est plutôt une logique d'individus
individualisme maintenant on commence à
avoir des étudiants dès la première
année s'intéresser au tissu associatif
est finalement valoriser son engagement
au terme de leur cursus
de nombreuses animations ponctuent le
festival tout au long de la journée
tournoi sportif buvette ateliers et bien
entendu le concert ouvert à tous de
boulevard des airs
voilà et puis faut toujours rester dans
le domaine du scolaires pour les lycéens
sans affectation il existe un dispositif
qui s'appelle sos rentrée explications
avec olivier maniscalco dans
l'informatique
informatique
youssef a 20 ans et vient de rater son
bac pour la seconde fois la scène du
système scolaire il cherche désormais
une formation professionnalisante pour
se relancer en quête de solutions il
s'est donc rendu ce mercredi après midi
au bureau d'yves une information
jeunesse à versailles pour l'opération
sos rentrée sur place de nombreux
intervenants et que les jeunes centre
d'information et d'orientation
professionnelle recrutement des armées
ou écoles de la deuxième chance le choix
est large l'occasion pour youssef de
rencontrer des professionnels ou des
conseillers pour définir au mieux sa
future orientation ce matin je suis
parti
une école informatique qu'on m'avait
recommandé à paris et voilà tout était
complet donc je cherche en attente de
formation et je suis venu aujourd'hui
puisque à la porte ouverte donc je
m'attendais à ce qui est des réponses à
mes questions et brèche les élus nous
l'idée en tant que généraliste de
l'information c'est d'inviter les
référents sur le département des
yvelines est de proposer le maximum de
possibilités selon les profils des
jeunes on accueille au préalable jeunes
donc ici à l'extérieur on va essayer
décrypter avec lui sa demande ses
besoins et en fonction de cela on va le
diriger vers le ou les partenaires qui
vont pouvoir répondre à ces questions et
approfondir avec lui sur ces thématiques
l'art une fois le contact établi ce sont
les organismes sollicités qui assureront
un suivi avec ces jeunes de ces
d'inscription pour une formation cv ou
lettre de motivation pour un employeur
la prise en charge continuera jusqu'à ce
qu'une solution soit trouvée
à l'esport maintenant prenez un feed
back in town un volant un peu
particulier quelques instants et vous
échauffer bien la paume de votre main
avant de jouer et vous pouvez pratiquer
le pkk ce sport brésilien était en
démonstration à la base de loisirs de 50
à l'occasion de la deuxième édition de
sentez vous sport anthony rech elodie
moines démonstration
rassurez vous votre téléviseur est bien
réglé ces quatre joueurs n'ont pas de
raquette et pourtant il semble bien sûr
un terrain de badminton mais il s'essaye
à la peteca ans ça se joue avec un filet
de badminton et le principe c'est
d'arriver à marquer le point en faisant
passer le volant de l'autre côté donc du
filet avec un maximum de trois passes de
chaque côté du terrain
pour marquer un point il faut que la
peteca ce gros volant à plumes touche le
sol et ici c'est la paume de la main qui
sert de raquette même si la précision
n'est pas toujours au rendez vous et la
main un peu fatigué après quelques
matchs le concept est adopté j'ai
vraiment découvert aujourd'hui je savais
même pas que ça existait donc vraiment
découverte totale aujourd'hui et je
pense à refaire sans hésiter c'est plus
dur que le badminton le volley mais il
ya des automatismes à acquérir déjà
oublié qu'on a on n'a pas de raquette
dans la main
utilisez uniquement sa main donc voilà
ça vient pas forcément naturellement
mais voilà au bout d'un peu de temps et
d'un peu de pratique je pense qu'on
s'amuse assez rapidement la peteca est
originaire du brésil mélange de volley
ball et de badminton ce sport
traditionnel et le plus populaire après
le football et s'il n'y a pas encore de
fédérations en france nicolas et muriel
entendent bien devenir de vrais ce match
heures de p tit k
7 8 week-end est presque terminée allez
une dernière date à retenir pour vos
loisirs de ce week-end le festival
chantier d'art et de scènes de
voisins-le-bretonneux cela se passe à
l'espace de covile des contes jeune
public seront proposées samedi après
midi entre 16 heures et 17 heures le
délai très très court à partir de 8 ans
et puis une soirée cabaret est
programmée le samedi soir il ya du rock
et de la performance est bien un prof un
bon c'est un joyeux mélange donc à
découvrir samedi soir dès 20h30 à
l'espace decaux villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux merci de votre
attention à très bientôt et surtout
excellent week-end à vous
oui